I skipped work to be here today I'm glad
you're here don't worry your boss
approved thanks I was dying to ask you
like when you hopped into the um
resident orientation and took the floor
because like no one was asking any
questions because we were like afraid to
lean into that phone yeah of course
after that whole thing I was like [__]
like I should have asked him like a bold
question and then but you know what like
I'm glad I didn't I'm glad I waited it
out because like first aid I would have
been like kind of edgy I don't know but
I'm glad as long as it comes from a good
place brother it's always right yeah
yeah well first day last day and every
day in between as long as the [__] that
comes out of your mouth comes from a
good place it's always right yeah that's
why I was so down on myself I was like
why because I I thought of it after that
what about not giving a [__] about that
don't beat yourself up yeah yeah you're
right you're right I'm loving the
residency one more month to go
um I'm gonna keep grinding I skipped
work to be here today I'm glad you're
here don't worry your boss approved
thanks